hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo
hallo hallo ich lache mit sandra und
lukas du bist du vielleicht schwul bist
was machst du gegen das stark ich bin
cherry und ich zeige dir wie du dich mit
worten heide bleibst du pool und sagst
einfach sterben
[Musik]
wie schmecken
das haben das ist nicht bei mir
angekommen dass es kann anders
stattfinden aber ist nichts wert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
nein wir waren jetzt an was abendessen
und die wir waren wir was zu abend isst
und sander wollte unbedingt dass ihr
altes trikot von arminia bielefeld ich
weiß nicht so jungwald hängt in einem
restaurant in hamburg sandras ehemaliges
das aber war die stelle wecker und 4 uhr
mal gelesen
[Gelächter]
das andere mikroben der angehalten
[Musik]
ich stelle mein wecker um 4 uhr auf 36
und er denkt sich nur so kommen früchte
sammeln aber cooles auto sind
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das wenn man integration nein ich frage
mich warum ich ständig pleite bin meine
kreditkartenabrechnungen 15.000 euro im
casino verspielt
[Musik]
18.500 euro im bordell ausgegeben
das teil nicht aber das teil riecht nach
den alkohol und das teil am plaza partie
es ist so war es sogar genauso meine mom
auch immer so im supermarkt kann man
jetzt punkte beim tabellen 17 high und
hungrig war schon jetzt kommt schreibt
das magazin
[Musik]
ich bin längst unter der dusche sagt
japans dessen browser noch die spanier
wenn es lässt den kopf gehalten und
dürften einchecken weil orangensaft
verschüttet wurde
die heißt messen echt oder cristiano
ronaldo ronaldinho ist aber dass sein
echter name das bleibt alles so wie hier
ist nichts dran
egal ob du hier werden andreas er soll
es also nicht gut aus
[Gelächter]
mach dir mal weiter nicht will nicht
gegen die stimme verschlagen
ich will nicht im englischen schmoren
lässt diese videos sind so leute die
bauen so puls mitten im urwald und so
wahrscheinlich alles fähig und so hab so
was machen jetzt aber im endeffekt
niemand 60 im römischen zahlen system
[Musik]
der war wie stark ein
er hat sie ja so halver
[Applaus]
die mit betone
warum
warum macht man das nimmt den beklagten
bezirken des fotografen egal
waffenbesitz geben bis körperverletzung
[Gelächter]
nicht immer wieder wenn leute auf mich
zukommen und erhält lich autoren und
foto man ohne zu fragen dann werde ich
einfach sei
der king der doppelmoral hat gesprochen
also dass nutzer geil
er kommt auch immer eines nicht so
fernen kontinenten
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was ist wenn sie eine glatze
ich würde joghurt oder nutella auf ihren
kopf machen ihre glatze damit verdenken
willst du auch das ist ja von den
volleys sandra nicht jeder sich auch
wieder eine vorbilder ab schwitzt du
auch so zusammen ich habe mich heute
auch wieder auf tik tok verliebt dann
herausgefunden dass das mädel 16 ist
muss man auch die ausweise schicken
bevor man sich so an wie alt war habe
ich jetzt nicht einfach erklären finger
der verkackt erst so langsam
der ist auch richtig dumm dieser finger
kann so gar nichts irgendwie das ist so
voll der dumme finger daumen ist ultra
op hat kein anderes tier so richtig
daumen krass gibt die beiden sind auch
einfach heftig altmann alles mit drei
fingern machen aber dieser finger die
ist so wie wenn ich mal richtig bewegen
aber das ist mit den zähnen genauso ein
gebrauchter menschen und 210
[Musik]
ein schönes spiel aber am ende schönes
spiel und der städte mit dass heute
wieder seine lieben freunde